[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui nous recevons une
personnalité yvelinoise qui nous parle
d'une autre personnalité yvelinoise
françois guillaume lorrain
bonjour un jours merci d'être sur le
plateau de tv 78 pour ce vip que l'on va
vous consacrez vous êtes journaliste au
point responsable de la rubrique
histoire vous êtes écrivain et vous avez
qu une dizaine d ouvrages dont le
dernier s'intitule louis xiv
l'enfant roi et c'est donc l'objet de
votre venue
voilà alors j'ai dit que vous aviez
petit côté biennois tout de même c'est
dû à vos études
oui j'ai fait ma première et terminale
au lycée hoche à versailles et je venais
juste de l'autre côté de des
hauts-de-seine de saint cloud mais j'ai
gardé beaucoup d'attachés avec avec
versailles vient ce oui vous les
librairies
j'étais venu souvent avec l'association
paroles d'encre jeux ateliers numériques
ou bien dans différents endroits vers
file senior histoire de livres vous avez
à gérer les différences voilages anime
beaucoup de conférence au salon
dulic de versailles et vous êtes venu
dans la librairie la suite
à quelle occasion avec le dernier livre
l'avant dernier livre maintenant quoi
vous êtes de la famille qui était une
très longue enquête un peu folle un peu
un peu désespéré à partir d'une taxe
commémorative que j'avais croisé à paris
près de la sorbonne et qui était
consacré un impôt view slave inconnu
patriotes yougoslave qui avaient été
tués en pleine guerre en 43 par les
allemands dans la rue voilà ce que vous
avez entrepris de retrouver ses traces
oui j'aime bien mené des livres un peu
difficile à partir et la difficulté
oui j'aime bien le chemin en tout cas
j'aime bien le chemin j'aime pas trop
arriver enfin je suis arrivé jusqu'à
jouer mais met donc j'aime bien la quête
je fais beaucoup d' enquête et à partir
d'une crasse vous savez d'une là cet
homme avait apparemment laissé qu'une
plaque
on avait organisé son hommage sur sa
glace il n'y avait rien sur lui et rien
que ça ça m'avait excité j'avais dit
mais que s'est-il passé ce jour là d'où
venaient-ils ou allait-il qu'avait-il
fait et pourquoi on lui a rendu hommage
et qu'est ce qu'il y avait derrière
cette gstl y vous vous évaluez le prix
de l'histoire contemporaine et les 19
ans mais qui avait été renvoyé en plus
haut panthéon ce qui est très bien on
rentre je suis rentré de mon vivant
pente et voilà des gens suis sorti oui
mais bon c'est petit mais retourner au
plus que parfait
alors là aujourd'hui on vous avez écrit
donc d'autre livre est un livre qui
s'appelle l'homme de lyon sur l'enfance
de votre père les enfants dans le cinéma
est là à nouveau une histoire d'enfants
c'est un thème qui vous est cher
oui je
je travaille beaucoup sur le trauma en
fait alors ça peut être le cinéma qui
traumatise les enfants du cinéma j'ai
retrouvé en fait tous les enfants qui
ont marqué le cinéma français notre
mémoire notre imaginaire et chez qui ce
livre cette année chez grasset
maintenant c'est au livre de poche et
donc zazie dans le métro la guerre des
boutons l'enfant sauvage et qu'elle sait
encore à tous ceux qui nous ont marqués
dans différentes générations
ce qui m'intéressait c'était comment en
fait le cinéma c'est en fait ce sont des
inconnus célèbres alors on les connaît à
travers le rôle me connaît sait pas qui
est comment en fait le cinéma avait
bouleversé leur vie donc je leur ai
demandé de raconter avec l'art avant
pendant et après ok alors lui vous lui
avez demandé quoi donc deux choses
d'abord comment on considère ce roman
roman historique roman vrai c'est à dire
que
j'ai fait mes devoirs ce qui est le
minimum syndical j'ai lu j'ai fait mes
devoirs
c'est là que j'ai lu les mémoires de
l'époque des témoins des proches de
louis xiv et son valet de chambre
la confidente la porte la confidente de
la reine maud ville samer envie d'aller
voir tout les admissibles et voilà les
sources de première main ou de seconde
main est ce qu'il a il ya des écrits lui
même le calme et adultes après j'avais
pas et son enfance très peu très peu il
y en a on a plutôt parlé il y en a un
qui en a parlé assez mal c'est saint
simon j'allais dire oui à sa place et de
manière assez d'efforts mais en dix ans
passant saint-simon n'aimait pas le 14
et donc de quillan occasion de dire du
mal profité pour dire en gros pour
résumer on l'a laissée à l'abandon ce
teint il a été entourée d'idiots et il
n'a pas été éduquée voilà ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut
il a été au contraire à s'écraser le
professeur will est dit choqué et donc
il a été initié très tôt aux affaires à
droite par sa mère à gauche par son
parrain mazarine hasard oui parce quelle
heure il est
il est orphelin de père louis xiii très
jeune à 5 ans les rois cinq ans et roi
du de fait à 5 ans il est né à saint
germain en laye il meurt à versailles
bien sûr et donc quelles sont les
sources les plus intéressantes à votre
évident c'est que la porte est
intéressant parce que
il raconte un peu laissé le seul qui qui
fait comprendre fait sentir un peu la
dureté en fait de cette absence puisque
bon il est plongé dans la fronde c'est à
dire en fait oui ton maire de lesquin
excusez moi le maire de requins c'est à
ce moment là le pouvoir et la peur
d'être est l'hôte est très difficile et
il ya une convergence des luttes
il ya le parlement qui se rebellent il
ya les bourgeois ex-rebelles a ensuite
il ya les princes qui se mettent de la
partie contre jusqu'au cousins germains
grand condé qui est le héros de l'époque
donc il a quel âge est à cette époque la
locataire entre 9 et 13 14 ans d'accord
il vit cette période de la fronde ou
finalement tourné contre lui oui tous à
matha - contre lui que contre mazarin et
d'ailleurs mazars l'utilisent un peu
comme une mascotte comme un pif m
parce qu'il la seule seul vestige du
pouvoir qui ne soit pas totalement
décrié honni on aime encore on a une
sorte tendresse de pitié qu'on a pour
les enfants et donc c'est l'enfant voit
donc il le promène sur les armes et sur
le front au près dans les provinces
auprès des parlements qui se rebellent
il lui demande de répondre nous ne pas
répondre donc il initie très tôt à ses
affaires et a glissé sa marionnette
pardon un petit peu un petit peu tout
mais une marionnette qui dont il
n'obtient pas simplement les films et
qui même à qui il inculque des valeurs
politiques
une sorte de bon gouvernement en fait
des leçons qu'il va qu'il va qu'il va
tirer très vite autre source
intéressante c'est brienne le seul ami
qu on lui concède qui vient jouer avec
lui dans l'allée royale au thème de
l'enfance la petite enfance
il n'a pas vraiment une au fond ce
jusqu'à sept ans ça va il y au
gouvernement d dans les mains des femmes
voilà qui qui le laisse aller il ya une
petite épisode - dont j'ai fait un
chapitre il a fui le palais royal il
fait une fugue vers les tuileries
d'ailleurs il manque de se noyer dans
avec sa petite amie qui nie la finul
chambrière et parce qu'il n'a pas encore
le sens des hiérarchies
j'avais lu à chaque fois je lis des
petites des petits bouts et puis le
romancier prend le relais l'historien
sel c'est toujours le relais parce que
vous dites il ya certains épisodes quand
on les choisit bien qu'ils sont de
formidables canevas pour modé voilà
alors que ce genre d'épisode par exemple
il ya on a parlé de la de la fronde il
ya ce moment clé de l'invasion du palais
royal par le peuple
ça c'est un moment où louis avec sa mère
est déjà parti à deux reprises de nuit
comme comme un voleur il a fui vers
reuil puis vers saint germain et le
peuple déteste que le roi les fasse faux
bond et quitte sa capitale c'est comme
c'est une trahison c'est un désaveu
c'est que c'est comme une déclaration de
guerre
et donc là la paz la capitale elle
bourhis de bruit de rumeurs comme quoi
il va nous être fuite et donc le peuple
va rentrer en colère dans les palais et
puis dans dans les salles du palais
royal et puis dans la chambre et un
d'autriche demande à son fils de feindre
de dormir pour rassurer le peuple
et là vous avez ce moment là où devant
cette figure de d'enfants qui semble
endormi et dans les bras de morphée
le peuple se purge de sa colère ce
peuple presque pré révolutionnaire
serait presque à déchirer le rideau et
se met à s'agenouiller à prier pour le
salut de son petit roi et ce moment là
où le petit roy est humilié parce qu'il
est forcé de jouer la comédie parle de
ce peuple et 2 il s'empresse que la
laine et peuple sauf à 60 sur sa nuque
et évidemment fondateur traumatisant et
je pense que j'ai construit un peu tout
toute cette réflexion très psychologique
sur cet enfant sur l'idée qu' il va
n'avoir de cesse en fait de se mettre à
distance de construire un fossé ou
d'arrière et de se construire des scènes
versailles sera la radicalisation de la
mise en scène le roi machines déjà avant
d'aller jusqu'à versailles déjà
adolescent il met aussi il est quand
même passionné dans son à la pompe c'est
son souffle son oxygène la danse c'est
vital pour lui parce qu'il n'a pas
d'amis il a rien donc voilà il est à la
danse et de mettre en scène des ballets
dette un peu chef d'orchestre l'afrique
peut être le roi pour de vrai parce que
souvent on lui demande d'être le roi
mais d'obéir à d'autres exactair donc
l'affrètement d'entendre les doléances
d'écouter les remontrances il ya un peu
humilié par le et donc il est même fou
était aussi pas par sa mère sur ordre de
sa mère parce que c'est ça aussi
l'ambivalence des personnages à dire que
il et il voudrait être roi mais on lui
rappelle aussi qu'il n'est qu'un enfant
et quand ils on lui demande d'être
heureux et de subir les les obligations
du droit il voudrait être un enfant et
donc la scène du théâtre il très tôt
c'est étonnant il
il fait il s'occupe de l'écriture de ce
héros l'invasion rien fait
donc là il est sous les projecteurs à
l'unité les rênes admirer admirer
intouchable inaccessible et il peut
dicter c'est lui qui donne le rythme il
a très vite appris
la majesté et la lenteur il a appris à
contrôler son corps
cette offre ça guillaume lorrain est
bien géré cette amo passionnant pour
immoralité
on va peut-être finir sur moi je pense
son coût de majesté alors qu'ils voient
qui m'impressionne le plus puisqu'il n'a
qu'à te relancer l'arrestation du grand
rival politique du dernier qui reste la
fin d'enfants de quelqu'un du nul de
rennes
oui qui est quand même la javel de
l'époque bill et au point un stratagème
a coincé pour faire venir le cardinal au
louvre et le cardinal se méfie sent bien
que sa dernière heure est arrivée
donc c'est presque comme dans une
attaque à jalawla à l'âge adulte noces à
cet acte de très politique c'est un peu
comme stratège le jeune violaine de la
fontaine le jeune lion qui fait venir
dans son antre le renard cardinal de
retz et qui est qui et qui le
circonscrit et qu'il y paraît dans les
annales qui le rassure tout va bien se
passer mais en fait il a mis au point
avec des hommes de main une mise en
scène là aussi est sur une phrase qui va
prononcer les hommes de main doit se
jeter ce cas le même mot de passe
un mot de passe à la à 14 ans oui c'est
quand même bizarre qu'un élève
exane voilà après d'artagnan le prend en
charge comme hazard à 120 et après
découvrons faire au termine ce livre
avait recouvert de versailles qui va
être ça c'est vrai qu'il a fait une
visite adolescents ou alors moi je me
suis je me suis autorisé à mettre en
scène cette visite dans le manoir de son
père malade ce qui est une manière de
boucler
le livre continue voilà et ce père qu'il
n'a pas connu et dont j'ai retrouvé un
tableau de louis xiii
justement dans versailles en train de
chasser je me suis dit que c'était bien
de finir sur un sur un adolescent qui
regarde son père mort mais dans un
tableau dans cette chasse et qui pense à
son père et l'avenir est devant lui mais
est ce qu ils étaient 6 millions que ça
loup 14
ce n'est pas une question simplement la
communauté pour asseoir avec certaines
personnes oui alors c'est un homme à
femmes c'est un nouveau carnage qui est
jeune on y met toujours dans le sens
d'une divination d'une mise en scène de
sa propre personne
d'abord apollon et c'est un homme à
femmes et je pense aussi parce que se
livrent le raconte
il a subi de multiples ruptures très tôt
me coûter des millions de pistes
un livre passionnant à lire même si on
croit connaître en fait on découvre
plein de choses et c'est important de
connaître l'enfance des hommes et des
grands hommes
d'autant plus merci françois guillaume
lorrain à très bientôt j'espère revoir
au revoir
[Musique]